From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Father's Day is here.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。父亲节到了。
I was about 9 or 10, and my parents were splitting up. And we lived in a very small rural town in North Dakota. And my dad, he left. And he left the house and he got an apartment in a city. And he's a farmer. To go and see him somewhere where there was no lawn, or pets, or field, or trees, it was just that, in itself, was strange. Plus the fact that he was there alone.
我当时大概9或10岁，父母正在闹离婚。我们住北达科他州一个非常小的乡村小镇。我爸爸，他离开了。他搬出了家，在城里租了一间公寓。他是个农夫。去一个没有草坪、没有宠物、没有田野、也没有树木的地方看他，这本身就让我觉得很奇怪。再加上他独自一人住在那里。
The first time Leah and her sister and brother saw their dad's apartment after their parents separated, they were uncomfortable. The whole separation made them uncomfortable. They hadn't seen him in weeks. And then there was the apartment itself.
莉娅和她的姐姐弟弟在父母分居后第一次见到爸爸的公寓时，他们感到很不自在。整个分居过程都让他们感到不自在。他们已经几周没见到他了。而且那间公寓本身也让他们不舒服。
We went up the stairs and it was a three flat behind the grocery store, across from the library. You know, it had that apartment smell of like cabbage in the hallway. And then, we went in and it was like a living room, and then a kitchen, and then a bathroom. And I remember I was like, wait, where's the bedroom? And he's like, that's the great part. You know, this is the cool part. See those doors, go open the doors. And I went over and opened the doors and there's just like metal frame. And that's the bed. And it's called a Murphy bed. I'd never seen one before. He said, you pull it down. Pull it down. And I pulled it down and it made this really awful noise, kind of creaked like, errr. Like it needed to be oiled.
我们走上楼梯，那是在杂货店后面、图书馆对面的一栋三层公寓。你知道，走廊里有那种公寓特有的卷心菜味。我们走进去，里面就像一个客厅，接着是厨房，然后是浴室。我记得我当时想，等等，卧室在哪？他说，那才是最棒的部分。你知道，这才是酷的地方。看到那些门了吗，去把门打开。我走过去打开门，里面只有一个金属框架。那就是床。它叫墨菲床（折叠床）。我以前从没见过。他说，你把它拉下来。拉下来。我把它拉下来，它发出了非常可怕的声音，那种吱呀声，咯吱。就像需要上油了一样。
And I hated seeing it. It was like a lumpy mattress at there was a thin blanket on it. It just didn't look like it was very good quality or comfortable. And we would sit on it sometimes to watch TV. And I remember just thinking, this is so weird to sit on a bed and watch TV.
我讨厌看到它。就像一个凹凸不平的床垫，上面盖着一条薄毯子。看起来质量一点也不好，也不舒服。我们有时会坐在上面看电视。我记得我当时就在想，坐在床上看电视真是太奇怪了。
It seemed really pathetic and lonely. And it's lonely and depressing anyway because you know your parents are splitting up. But then to see what your dad is living and it's not nice. It was so incongruous with who I knew him to be. I mean he's someone who belongs outside, working outside, animals, pets, agriculture, all of that. And here he is in this apartment.
这看起来真的很可怜、很孤独。而且这本来就让人感到孤独和沮丧，因为你知道你的父母要分开了。但看到你爸爸住的地方，而且并不好，这和我认识的他格格不入。我的意思是，他是个属于户外、在户外工作、有动物、宠物、农业等等的人。而现在他却住在这间公寓里。
I even hated the word "apartment" for a while. I remember, like seeing it in books or reading it somewhere in the newspaper and being like, "Ugh, apartment. My dad lives in an apartment." I was really bothered by that.
有一段时间，我甚至讨厌“公寓”这个词。我记得在书里或报纸上看到它，心里就会想，“呃，公寓。我爸爸住在公寓里。”那真的让我很困扰。
Was that the first time you saw him so vulnerable?
那是你第一次见到他如此脆弱吗？
Yeah. I mean, he'd always been-- my horse used to get out, escape, and like run down the road for miles. And I wouldn't know what to do. And my dad would just calmly get in the car and go drive. And find him in the bean field and lead him back. I mean, he was my-- who else could do that? But here he is in this apartment. And yet, he seemed kind of cowed by it. The walls closed in on him. So I saw him as just being kind of helpless.
是的。我的意思是，他曾经——我的马以前经常跑出去，逃跑，沿着路跑上几英里。我不知道该怎么办。我爸爸总是冷静地坐进车里开车去追。然后在豆田里找到它，把它带回来。我的意思是，他曾是我的——还有谁能做到那样？但现在他住在这间公寓里。然而，他似乎被它压垮了。四壁向他合拢。所以我看到的他，只是一种无助。
As the years went on, did he resume his full size, or did he stay more like the picture that you had in that apartment?
随着岁月流逝，他恢复了往日的形象，还是保持着你在那间公寓里看到的样子？
No, that image was kind of-- he never regained the stature. He never regained the stature that he had before that moment and before that year that he lived there.
不，那种形象一直——他再也没有恢复到那种地位。他再也没有恢复到那一刻以及他住在那里那一年之前的样子。
Leah was nine. She says that if her parents hadn't split up, she probably would have had two or three more years where she would have kept her dad on that pedestal. Before adolescence would have hit and he would've come down to size anyway.
莉娅那时九岁。她说，如果她父母没有离婚，她大概还会多有两三年时间把爸爸捧在神坛上。在青春期到来之前，无论如何他都会走下神坛，恢复到平凡人的样子。
Your father gets knocked off the pedestal. And that would have happened if they had gotten divorced or not. But it was more jarring the way that it happened.
你的父亲被从神坛上拉了下来。无论他们是否离婚，这都会发生。但这种发生的方式更加令人震惊。
Do you regret that you lost those years of idealizing him, or do you think in the end it doesn't really matter?
你后悔失去了那些对他充满幻想的岁月吗，还是你认为到最后这其实并不重要？
I think it matters. I think that it really-- it was so painful and we were so young. You don't need that. Yeah, to make a difference, you need a few more years. You need to have it come to you on your own terms. I don't think that it's good when it happens in a way that you don't control. And the way that it came about for me wasn't really natural. It was very shocking. It was like one day he was there and two weeks later he definitely was not there.
我觉得这很重要。我觉得它真的——这太痛苦了，我们当时还太小。你不需要那样。是的，要造成这种改变，你需要多几年时间。你需要按自己的方式去认识这一点。我不认为这种事以一种你无法控制的方式发生是件好事。对我来说，它的发生并不自然。这非常令人震惊。就像有一天他还在那里，两周后他就彻底不在了。
Here's the story of everyone and their dad. Once, dad was on a pedestal. Then we got older and he came off the pedestal. And with some dads, that happens more or less, gracefully. With others, it is a quick, painful crash from which none of the participants ever recovers fully.
这是一个关于每个人和他们父亲的故事。曾经，父亲被捧在神坛上。后来我们长大了，他从神坛上走了下来。有些父亲走得还算从容。而对另一些人来说，这是一次迅速而痛苦的坠落，当事人中没有谁能完全恢复过来。
And how a father manages that descent from power, that transition to being human sized with his children, man, that is a test. That is really a test. And a lot of really decent guys have a hard time with it.
而一位父亲如何管理这种从权力之巅的坠落，这种在孩子面前转变为凡人的过程，天哪，这真是一种考验。这确实是一种考验。很多非常体面的人在这方面都很吃力。
Today on our radio program, we bring you three stories of fathers handling their falls off the pedestal as best they can.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们为大家带来三个关于父亲尽其所能处理坠落的故事。
Act One of our show, Driving the Divorce Mobile. What happens if your dad goes from hero to tooling around in a Corvette and honking at girls in one month.
第一幕，驾驶离婚专车。如果你爸爸在一个月内从英雄变成了开着科尔维特跑车对着女孩按喇叭的人，会发生什么。
Act Two, And if that Diamond Ring Don't Shine. Ian Brown explains the lengths a normal dad will go through to try to do right by his daughter on her birthday. And how this innocent wish led him and his wife to the most corrupt and most questionable birthday stunt they, or any of their friends, had ever heard of.
第二幕，如果那枚钻戒不闪耀。伊恩·布朗解释了一位普通父亲为了在女儿生日时尽量做到尽善尽美所付出的努力。以及这个天真的愿望是如何引导他和妻子走向他们，或是他们任何朋友听过的最腐败、最可疑的庆生活动。
Act Three, Legend of a Bankrobber's Son. What if your dad was never on a pedestal to start with? And yet, you find yourself still, somehow imitating him? Answers, stay with us.
第三幕，银行劫匪之子的传奇。如果你的爸爸从一开始就没在神坛上呢？然而，你却发现自己不知为何还在模仿他？答案，请留下来继续收听。
Act one, Driving the Divorce Mobile.
第一幕，驾驶离婚专车。
Kids whose parents divorce, like Leah, are often forced to see their parents as human size, all of a sudden, way before they want to. And if there is a separate culture in this country of divorce kids, this story is at the heart of its oral tradition. This story is swapped like trading cards. This story of parents and how they acted in those first few months after they split up. Those first few months when they were perfectly flawed human beings. And to start our show today, we've collected a few about fathers right after the divorce.
像莉娅这样父母离婚的孩子，往往被迫比他们预期得早得多，突然间将父母视为凡人。如果这个国家存在一种离婚子女的亚文化，这个故事就是其口头传统的精髓。这个故事像交易卡一样被交换。这个关于父母在分居后头几个月行为的故事。那些他们表现得极其不完美的头几个月。为了开始我们今天的节目，我们收集了一些关于离婚后父亲们的故事。
Our dad would take my brother and I out on Sundays, like every Sunday. And this one time he took us out and he wouldn't tell us where we were going until we pulled up to this shopping mall that had this fair going on. And so I just remember seeing all the rides and you hear the music of the fair. We're so excited. And he went to the ticket booth and he bought a big wad of tickets. And we just knew this was going to be a great day. And the first ride we went on was this airplane ride where you go around in a circle in an airplane. And you could go up and down and you had a gun. You could fire the gun. It would make this noise.
我爸爸以前每周日都会带我和我弟弟出去，几乎每个周日。有一次他带我们出去，在我们停到一个正在举办集市的商场前，他都不肯告诉我们要去哪里。我记得看到所有的游乐设施，听到了集市的音乐。我们太兴奋了。他走到售票处买了一大把票。我们当时就知道这会是美好的一天。我们玩的第一项游乐设施是那种飞机，你在里面绕着圈转。你可以上下升降，你还有一把枪。你可以开枪。它会发出声音。
And I remember, like every time we would circle-- our dad was watching us as we'd circle around. And every time we'd go around, we'd pull the stick shift so we would rise up just as we passed our dad to show off in front of him. And my dad would wave to us as we would go by. It was a really nice moment. And then, I think probably on the third or fourth time around we noticed he started talking to this guy beside him. And we were like wondering, who's that guy that dad's talking to? And then the next time around they were closer together and we were like wondering, who is this guy? What's going on? And then the next time around, the next thing we know this guy's got my dad kind of like in a headlock or he's just got my dad's shirt pulled up over his back. He's like wrestling him and trying to punch him. My brother and I are in shock. And so we kept going around. And like instead of pulling on the stick shift, we were just frozen. We were constantly in the air circling around.
我记得，每次我们绕圈——我爸爸都在看着我们绕圈。每次我们转过去，我们就会拉动操纵杆，这样在经过爸爸面前时我们就能升高，在他面前炫耀。爸爸经过时会向我们挥手。那是一个非常美好的时刻。然后，我想大概是第三或第四次转圈时，我们注意到他开始和身边的一个人说话。我们当时在想，那个和爸爸说话的人是谁？下次转过来时，他们靠得更近了，我们就在想，这人是谁？怎么回事？再下一次转过来时，我们看到那个人已经把我爸爸锁喉了，或者只是把爸爸的衬衫拽到了背上。他在摔跤，试图打他。我和弟弟都惊呆了。所以我们继续转圈。比起拉操纵杆，我们当时只是僵住了。我们在空中不停地绕着圈。
And by now, a whole crowd had gathered. And they're kind of egging everyone on. Like hit him, hit him. And I guess the one image that stays in my mind is seeing my dad's exposed pale, white back because his shirt was up around his shoulders.
这时，周围已经聚集了一大群人。他们有点在煽风点火。像打他，打他。我想一直留在脑海里的一个画面就是看到爸爸露出的苍白背部，因为衬衫被拽到了肩膀上。
And finally when the ride had ended we jumped out of the plane and ran over to my dad. By then I think the crowd had separated the two of them. I remember this lady coming up to my dad saying, oh, you should have punched him. You should have hit him in the face. And my dad was like, oh, you kids want to go on some more rides? And he took us over to this other ride and says, oh, here. Take some tickets. And we were just like, I want to go home now. And just kind of put a damper on the day.
最后，当游乐设施结束时，我们跳下飞机跑向爸爸。那时我想人群已经把他们两个分开了。我记得一位女士走到我爸爸身边说，噢，你应该打他的。你应该打他的脸。我爸爸说，噢，孩子们想再去玩点别的吗？他带我们去了另一个设施，说，噢，给。拿些票吧。我们当时就像，我现在想回家。这让那天的心情有点扫兴。
From what my dad was telling us, he said, oh, I think that guy was drunk or something. He thought I was calling him names while we were on the ride. He tried to, I guess, have a moral lesson out of it once we got back into the car. And he was saying, fighting is not the answer kind of thing. Always count to 10. But I think by the time you get to eight, your shirt's already off your back. What are you going to do?
据我爸爸告诉我们，他说，噢，我觉得那家伙喝醉了还是怎么的。他以为我们在坐游乐设施时在骂他。回到车里后，我想他试图进行一次道德教育。他说，打架不是解决问题的办法。凡事数到10。但我认为当你数到8的时候，你的衬衫已经从背上掉下来了。你还能怎么办？
When I think of my father pre-divorce, I think of a very kind of dry, retiring, very British kind of man. Everything he did was very measured, very calm. We're talking about a guy who made muzak his kind of personal soundtrack. He found this radio station out of Vermont that played muzak all day and he kind of wandered around humming. And so I'd hear him wandering around the house-- [HUMMING "THE GIRL FROM IPANEMA"]
当我想到离婚前的父亲时，我想到的是一个非常内敛、安静、典型的英国男人。他所做的一切都非常有分寸，非常冷静。我们说的是一个把背景音乐（Muzak）当作个人原声带的人。他从佛蒙特州找了一个整天播放背景音乐的电台，然后到处哼着调子。所以我经常听到他在屋里走来走去——[哼唱《来自伊帕内玛的女孩》]
But once my parents got divorced, he joined the Y. He started working out religiously. And suddenly he was saying incredibly bizarre things like, you know, I'm going to the gym and I'm going to wail on my pecs.
但父母离婚后，他加入了基督教青年会。他开始极其狂热地锻炼。突然间，他开始说一些极其怪异的话，比如，你知道，我要去健身房，我要练练我的胸肌。
When he was first divorced, he didn't really have a place to live. It was kind of a hasty divorce. And so he was having us live in his office. And we just visited him on the weekends. And his office consisted of this sort of psychedelic blue couch. And of course, the shaggy rug. And unfortunately, no bathroom. So he would actually get me to go to the bathroom with him on the roof into a Coke bottle. And somehow he made this fun to go out into the roof and practice my aim. It actually became like a fun thing to do that I actually look forward to during the day. And I have to really give him credit for that.
他刚离婚时，并没有地方住。那是场仓促的离婚。所以他让我们住在他的办公室里。我们只是周末去看他。他的办公室里有那种迷幻的蓝色沙发。当然，还有毛茸茸的地毯。但不幸的是，没有浴室。所以他竟然让我陪他一起去屋顶，对着一个可乐瓶小便。不知为何，他把去屋顶练习瞄准变成了一件有趣的事。这实际上变成了一件我白天非常期待的趣事。我真的要为此归功于他。
He was always insisting on showing me this non-existent muscle growth. I'd be sitting watching TV and I could hear him thundering down the stairs and, "Jamie!" Sure enough, I'd go out and there at the bottom of the stairs he'd be naked, flexing like this divorcee pumping-iron Arnold Schwarzenegger. He'd want me to grab his biceps to see how they were growing. It was just absolutely horrible.
他总是坚持要向我展示他那并不存在的肌肉生长。我正坐在那看电视，就能听到他轰隆隆地跑下楼梯，喊道，“杰米！”果然，我走出去，在楼梯底部，他赤身裸体，像那个离婚后疯狂练铁的阿诺德·施瓦辛格一样摆着姿势。他想让我抓他的二头肌看看它们长得怎么样了。这简直太可怕了。
I moved in with him when I was about 10 years old. I wasn't used to certain habits of his and one of them was where he would sit in the living room with a hairdryer on this head, completely naked. And it's surreal enough to see your father under a hairdryer. I mean, I'm talking like the old ones from the '50s.
我在10岁左右搬去和他一起住。我不习惯他的一些习惯，其中之一就是他会坐在客厅里，头顶着吹风机，全身赤裸。看着自己的父亲头顶吹风机，这已经够超现实的了。我的意思是，我说的是那种50年代的老式吹风机。
And I remember bringing over this friend of mine and we walk in and my dad's completely naked. And then we decide to just leave. And as we're leaving, my dad says, well, you guys going to go out and boogie tonight? Anyway, he's still in this kind of single-- he thought I was a single guy too.
我记得带了一个朋友过来，我们走进去，我爸爸完全没穿衣服。然后我们决定直接离开。当我们离开时，我爸爸说，嘿，你们今晚打算出去蹦迪吗？总之，他还是处于那种单身状态——他以为我也是个单身汉。
And of course, he started dating. And he'd tell me about these women. And he always insisted on calling them madame. There was Madame Farago and Madame Hardaway and Madame Wilson. And we never met any of these women, so they're like these phantom madames that I presume existed, but it was difficult. Because you're embarrassed of your father anyways. They're embarrassing. It's your dad. And then here he is gunning the Corvette at a light to impress a girl. And there you are, 10 years old, in this popsicle-colored green Corvette that's rusted and has a hole in the floor.
当然，他开始约会了。他会跟我谈起这些女人。他总是坚持称她们为“夫人”。有法拉戈夫人、哈达威夫人和威尔逊夫人。我们从未见过这些女人，所以她们就像是我推测存在的幻影夫人，但这很困难。因为你本来就对你父亲感到尴尬。她们很尴尬。那是你爸爸。而现在，他为了给女孩留下深刻印象在红绿灯处猛踩科尔维特的油门。而你，一个10岁的孩子，坐在那辆生锈的、地板上有个洞的冰棒绿科尔维特里。
We talked to a half dozen dads about all this and we discovered that for the most part, they did not have specific memories of moments when they realized that their kids were seeing them differently.
我们和六位父亲谈到了所有这些，我们发现大部分人对于孩子开始以不同眼光看他们的时刻并没有具体的记忆。
Maybe the kids notice because for a child, any kind of change from what they're used to is huge. Or maybe, it's just that the dads, understandably, wanted to believe that they were not diminished in their children's eyes and didn't let themselves notice a change. Occasionally, a dad told us a story like this one.
也许孩子们注意到了，因为对孩子来说，任何习惯性的改变都是巨大的。又或者，只是父亲们理所当然地想要相信自己在孩子眼中并没有变小，所以没让自己注意到这种变化。偶尔，一位父亲会告诉我们像这样的故事。
I call the boys every day and talk about whatever. How their day was. And one day I was on the phone with my eight year old, Alex. So we were having a conversation and there was a lull in the conversation. And then I sighed. I just went, ah, like that. And then he just asked me, lonely?
我每天都给孩子们打电话，聊任何事情。他们的一天过得怎么样。有一天我正和8岁的儿子亚历克斯通电话。我们正在聊天，谈话中出现了一段沉默。然后我叹了口气。我只是说，啊，那样。然后他问我，感到孤独吗？
I almost started to cry. I was so taken aback by his perception. And I was honest. I said yeah, when you go aren't around I'm lonely.
我差点哭出来。我被他的洞察力震惊了。我很诚实。我说是的，你不在的时候我很孤独。
But even in this case, this dad didn't really think that his kids saw him that differently since the divorce. Since seeing him so vulnerable. Since seeing him cry.
但即便在这种情况下，这位父亲也没有真正认为他的孩子们自从离婚后看他的眼光变得有多么不同。自从看到他如此脆弱之后。自从看到他哭之后。
One dad who did notice a change in his kid was Brian Masters in Wichita. Since he and his wife split up eight months ago, his young son started looking out for him. Taking care of him in ways he never had before the divorce.
威奇托市的布莱恩·马斯特斯是一位注意到孩子发生变化的父亲。自从他和妻子八个月前分居以来，他年幼的儿子开始照顾他。以他离婚前从未有过的方式关心他。
Probably the first thing that he started doing was helping me clean up, grabbing the Swiffer and going and doing the hardwood floors. And sweeping the porch. And going around and opening up windows to kind of freshen the place up. And you know, just sort of some of the kinds of things that you don't think of a kid even having on their radar screen.
他开始做的第一件事就是帮我打扫卫生，拿起静电拖把去擦硬木地板。打扫门廊。到处开窗让屋里通风。你知道，就是那些你根本想不到孩子会关注的事情。
What else would he do to try to be the responsible one around the house?
他还做了什么试图成为家里负责任的那个人？
He kind of runs through this little checklist on our way out the door. Do you have your cellphone? Did you turn off the oven? Is the back door locked? You know, little litany of things that he knows I'm going to be worried about later.
我们在出门前，他会过一遍这个小清单。你有手机吗？关烤箱了吗？后门锁了吗？你知道，他知道我之后会担心的那些琐事。
He's nine?
他九岁？
10.
10岁。
He's 10? Wow, that is so parental.
他10岁？哇，这太有家长范儿了。
Isn't it? Oh, I know. I would love it if that only made me happy. The fact is, it also makes me a little bit sad.
是吗？哦，我知道。如果这只是让我开心，我会很高兴。事实是，它也让我有点难过。
Because?
为什么？
Well, because no kid should be in that position. Kids should get to be kids.
嗯，因为没有孩子应该处于那种位置。孩子们应该有权利做孩子。
Has Marshall tried to fix you up?
马歇尔试着给你介绍对象了吗？
Not in the specific. But especially in the early going, Marshall would-- say we'd be sitting at a coffee shop and he'd be doing his homework and I'd be reading a magazine. And he'd look across the room and kind of nudge me and say, she's really pretty. I bet she's a good cook.
没有特别的。但在早期，马歇尔会——比如说我们在咖啡馆坐着，他在做家庭作业，我在读杂志。他会看向房间另一边，推推我说，她真的很漂亮。我打赌她一定很会做饭。
I love how the second sentence after she's really pretty is she's a good cook.
我喜欢他在说“她很漂亮”之后的第二句话是“她很会做饭”。
Yeah. I bet she's a good cook.
是的。我打赌她一定很会做饭。
Did you have to learn new things to cook after your wife left?
你妻子离开后，你不得不学着做饭吗？
I had to remember to cook. You know, which was the hardest part in the darkest days, was just remembering that kids need to be fed just darn near every day for things to go well. And occasionally, he would-- about 7:30, 8 o'clock at night he'd very casually say, you know what would be neat? Dinner.
我不得不记得去做饭。你知道，在最黑暗的日子里，最困难的部分就是记住孩子们几乎每天都需要吃饭，这样事情才能顺利进行。偶尔，他会在晚上7:30、8点左右非常随意地说，你知道什么会很棒吗？晚餐。
See, one of the things that I've been thinking about is it's really hard for the child for their parent to be prematurely taken from them as the super person. But how hard is that for the dad?
看，我一直在思考的一件事是，对孩子来说，过早失去作为超人的父母是非常困难的。但这对父亲来说有多难？
It's a terrible experience. I mean, talk about a failure. And it was important to me to be able to legitimately reclaim some of that ground. Not just to appear to, but to actually reclaim some of that ground.
那是一种可怕的经历。我的意思是，谈谈失败感。对我来说，能够合法地夺回一些领地很重要。不仅仅是表面上，而是真正夺回一些领地。
Did you consciously try to reclaim it?
你有意识地试图夺回它吗？
Absolutely. Sure. You know, those weren't proud moment in my life to realize that my kid had begun to look out for me. That my kid had begun to become aware of the chinks in my armor.
绝对是。当然。你知道，意识到我的孩子开始关心我，意识到我的孩子开始注意到我盔甲上的裂缝，那不是我生命中骄傲的时刻。
What are you doing this Father's Day?
这个父亲节你打算做什么？
Well, I won't be doing anything with Marshall. Sunday is not one of the days that I get to spend with him. Unless we make some kind of a special arrangement to do so. And we haven't just yet, so I would suspect that Sunday will be a little poignant.
嗯，我不会和马歇尔在一起。周日不是我能和他待在一起的日子。除非我们做出某种特别安排。我们还没这样做，所以我猜周日会有一点伤感。
Because you'll be alone?
因为你会孤身一人？
Yeah.
是的。
It will be interesting to see if Marshall figures this out and steps in.
看看马歇尔是否能想通并介入，这将会很有趣。
I'm hopeful that he will and on another level, I'm kind of hopeful that the whole thing slides passed him and that it isn't a concern for him. That would be strangely comforting to me.
我希望他会，但在另一个层面上，我有点希望这一切从他身边滑过，让他不必担心。那对我来说会是一种奇怪的安慰。
Why? Explain that. Why that would be a sign that things were maybe healthier?
为什么？解释一下。为什么那会是一个事情可能更健康的迹象？
If that were to happen, it would be an indication that he is less aware of my loneliness and less aware of my frailty. And a little less concerned about me.
如果发生那种情况，那就说明他不太意识到我的孤独，也不太意识到我的脆弱。对我少了一点关心。
Yeah.
是的。
That'd be a great problem to have. It'd be a great way to be alone on Sunday.
那将是个很好的问题。那将是在周日孤身一人的好方式。
Thanks to all the kids and dads who talked to us.
感谢所有与我们交谈的孩子和父亲们。
[MUSIC- "MY DAD" BY PAUL PETERSEN]
[音乐-保罗·彼得森的《我的爸爸》]
Act Two, And if that Diamond Ring Don't Shine. There are moments when a dad is tested. And on this Father's Day, let us examine one of them. A daughter's birthday. Ian Brown is a writer and a radio host for the Canadian Broadcasting Corporation. He has this story about what it means to be a dad who is merely human sized. He recorded this at a This American Life show that we did in front of live audiences in Boston, Chicago, and Los Angeles.
第二幕，如果那枚钻戒不闪耀。有些时刻是对父亲的考验。在这个父亲节，让我们审视其中之一。女儿的生日。伊恩·布朗是作家和加拿大广播公司的电台主持人。他有这个关于成为一名只是凡人大小的父亲意味着什么的故事。这是他在我们分别在波士顿、芝加哥和洛杉矶举办的现场演出中录制的。
No one arrives fashionably late for a seven year old's birthday party. That offends rule one of parental life-- never waste free babysitting.
没有人会为了七岁孩子的生日派对而姗姗来迟。那违反了家长生活的第一准则——绝不浪费免费的托儿时间。
But all seven guests at my daughter Haley's seventh birthday party weer dropped off by their parents mysteriously seven minutes early. That sort of behavior is just plain rude. It was like being swarmed by a gang from planet tiny. They drop their coats in the hall and immediately scattered to the farthest corners of the house, like some new, instantly contagious form of biological weapon.
但我女儿海莉七岁生日派对上的所有七位客人都被他们的父母神秘地早到了七分钟。这种行为简直太没礼貌了。就像被来自“小人国”的一帮人围住一样。他们把外套丢在门厅，立刻分散到房子的各个角落，就像某种新的、瞬间传播的生物武器。
And I staggered upstairs with a small mountain of coats in my arms. Which is not a chore I saw myself performing back when I was young and longing to be grown up. Even when I was 11, I wanted to be married. Because married people, I knew, had sex every night of their lives.
我怀里抱着一大堆外套摇摇晃晃地走上楼。这并不是我年轻时渴望长大时预想到的家务。甚至在我11岁时，我就想结婚。因为我知道，已婚的人每天晚上都能过性生活。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But that's another story. I was lugging coats.
但这又是另一个故事了。我当时正扛着外套。
And back downstairs, Trish, the mother of Katie, Haley's best friend, two best friends ago, Trish shot me a knowing look. Magician, right? How can you tell I said. Fiber optic wands by the forks. And that was the first hint that my wife and I might have gone slightly over the top birthday-wise. That we might have stepped over the strict moral boundary that separates caring, thoughtful parents, who believe in personal attention and quality time, from cheese balls like us, who try to buy their way into their children's hearts.
楼下，海莉两任前闺蜜的闺蜜凯蒂的妈妈翠西，给了我一个心照不宣的眼神。是魔术师吧？你怎么看出来的，我说。叉子旁边有光纤棒。那是第一个暗示，我和妻子在生日派对上可能有点过头了。我们可能越过了那条严格的道德界限——把关心、体贴、相信个人关注和高质量陪伴的父母，与我们这种试图用钱买进孩子心里的俗人区分开了。
It's easy to commit that social gaffe these days. My wife and I both work. The harder we work, the guiltier we feel. The more we want Haley's birthday parties to be-- well, visible from outer space would be gratifying. We'd been planning Haley's seventh birthday. Or to be slightly more accurate, my wife Johanna had been planning it and I'd been doing nothing. For weeks.
现在犯这种社交错误很容易。我和妻子都要工作。我们越努力，就越感到内疚。我们就越想让海莉的生日派对——嗯，如果能从外太空看到那才叫满足。我们一直在计划海莉的七岁生日。或者更准确地说，是我妻子乔安娜在计划，而我什么都没做。持续了几周。
What there was a cake or iced by professionals in the shape of a magician's top hat, which cost $30. Eight loot bags filled with thoughtful, age appropriate peanut free party favors at $15 a bag. And of course, the magician himself, at $150 for 2 hours. He called himself the Amazing Robert.
有专业人士装饰的魔术师高顶礼帽形状的蛋糕，花了30美元。八个装满贴心、适合年龄且不含花生的派对小礼品的礼品袋，每个袋子15美元。当然，还有魔术师本人，2小时150美元。他自称是“神奇罗伯特”。
I don't think he meant that ironically.
我不认为他是讽刺性的。
Now, I like to do something special on Haley's birthday. Still, don't you think, I said to my wife as she frantically tried to find a magician who wasn't booked three months in advance, don't you think we might be over amping?
现在，我喜欢在海莉生日时做点特别的事。不过，你不觉得，我对正疯狂寻找还没被提前三个月预订的魔术师的妻子说，你不觉得我们可能有点过度兴奋了吗？
But honey, if we don't go slightly crazy, Johanna said quite logically, some other parent will. Then what's Haley going to think? And anyway, do you have a better idea?
但亲爱的，如果我们不稍微疯狂一点，乔安娜非常合逻辑地说，其他家长也会这么做。那海莉会怎么想？再说，你有更好的主意吗？
And I did not have a better idea. My sole contribution to the magician party had been to suggest that we include a whoopee cushion in every loot bag. Or at least it was my idea to blow them up and put them in the loot bags pre-inflated.
我确实没有更好的主意。我对这场魔术师派对唯一的贡献就是建议我们在每个礼品袋里放一个放屁垫。或者至少，是我想把它们吹起来放进预先充好气的礼品袋里。
In the old days, when Haley was small, we kept her birthday simple. I learned that lesson when I lived in Los Angeles near Beverly Hills. In Beverly Hills, parents like their children's birthday parties to have a theme. And a fairly significant theme at that. Manifest destiny say, or a NASA moon shot. In LA, I never went to a birthday party that featured anything less than pony rides. And one mother actually gave out Gucci t-shirts in the loot bags. It was hard to compete with that.
过去，海莉小时候，我们让她生日过得很简单。我住在洛杉矶比佛利山庄附近时学到了那个教训。在比佛利山庄，家长喜欢孩子生日派对有主题。而且是一个相当隆重的主题。比如“昭昭天命”，或者NASA登月计划。在洛杉矶，我从未去过一个没有骑马环节的生日派对。有一位母亲甚至在礼品袋里发Gucci T恤。很难和那种竞争。
In an act of defiance, a friend of ours, a struggling writer, staged her daughter's birthday in a park of all places. The kids had a good enough time. They ran around and swung on swings and played tag. And generally reveled in a whole two hours when they weren't under the watchful eye of a nanny or armed response security. The grab bags contained what grab bags are supposed to contain, candy rather than Rolex watches. And afterwards, the Beverly Hills parents flocked, I mean literally flocked round our friend. Fabulous idea they said. Nature, who would've thought? Can I steal the theme?
作为一种反抗，我们的一位朋友，一个挣扎的作家，把她女儿的生日选在了一个公园里，那个地方。孩子们玩得很开心。他们四处奔跑、荡秋千、玩捉人游戏。总的来说，他们享受了整整两个小时，没有在保姆或武装安全人员的监视下。那些抓奖袋里装的是抓奖袋该有的东西——糖果，而不是劳力士手表。事后，比佛利山庄的父母们涌向了——我的意思是真的涌向了我们的朋友。妙招，他们说。大自然，谁能想到呢？我能借用这个主题吗？
But our friend Katharine is the queen of the less is more, easy on mummy birthday party. She says children want strong experiences, not new ones. Which is why last weekend for her daughter Mary's seventh birthday, Katharine invited six girls over to string gummy bears onto extra long bamboo satay skewers. That was the theme of the party. Skewering candies on a stick. There was some risk of eye injury and the entire gimmick seemed to have Freudian undertones.
但我们的朋友凯瑟琳是“少即是多，轻松当妈”生日派对的女王。她说孩子们想要的是强烈的体验，而不是新奇的。这就是为什么上周末她女儿玛丽七岁生日时，凯瑟琳邀请了六个女孩来把小熊软糖串在超长的竹签上。那就是派对的主题。把糖果串在棍子上。这有眼睛受伤的风险，整个花招似乎还有弗洛伊德式的潜台词。
The little girls kept saying, I'm going to stick this skewer up gummy's tiny butt. And giggling hysterically. But all in all, it was a winner. Only one girl barfed. The entire party cost $15. Canadian.
小女孩们不停地说，我要把这根签子捅进小熊的屁股里。然后歇斯底里地咯咯笑。但总而言之，它大获成功。只有一个女孩吐了。整个派对只花了15美元。加元。
It is true that Katharine had a pinata. Pinatas are excellent because they entail hitting an object violently with a stick. But those were the old pre-bacchanalian birthdays. By the time Haley turned five, the year of our most corrupt-- and therefore, most successful birthday-- we'd gone as low as a parent can go. We'd hired Human Barbie.
凯瑟琳确实有个皮纳塔（糖果罐）。皮纳塔很棒，因为它们涉及用棍子猛烈地击打一个物体。但那是以前那些派对前的生日。到了海莉五岁生日那天，即我们最腐败——因此也是最成功的一年——我们达到了家长的最低谷。我们雇了“人形芭比”。
For $300 Human Barbie dressed up in full size versions of Barbie doll outfits and came to your house. Human Barbie arrived in a Dodge Grand Caravan with Human Midge, her assistant. Two giant mobile racks of party dresses for the girls, a tea set in a case, and two chests of makeup. She dressed the kids, discussed the possibility of multiple careers, and fed them cake.
花了300美元，人形芭比穿着真人大小的芭比娃娃装扮来到家里。她开着一辆道奇大捷龙带着助手人形米奇来了。两排巨大的移动派对服装架，一个手提箱里的茶具，还有两箱化妆品。她给孩子们打扮，讨论多重职业的可能性，并喂她们吃蛋糕。
All our friends were completely horrified. I might as well have said, oh, this year Haley's having a crack party. We're having a cake made of crack too.
我们所有的朋友都完全惊呆了。我还不如说，哦，今年海莉要开一个可卡因派对。我们还有一个可卡因做的蛋糕。
My Canadian friends put this crassness down to the fact that Johanna, my wife, is an American.
我的加拿大朋友把这种粗俗归咎于乔安娜，我妻子，是个美国人。
But successful? Well, it was as if the Dalai Lama had made a stop at our house. The girls were hypnotized with awe. They spent most of the afternoon standing in a circle brushing human Barbie's hair.
但成功吗？好吧，那感觉就像达赖喇嘛在我们家停了一站。女孩们被深深震撼了。她们整个下午大部分时间都围成一圈给人形芭比梳头。
I had the feeling that secretly, quite a few mum's wouldn't have minded giving it a try themselves. As it turned out, I needn't have worried about the Amazing Robert, the magician, either. He was a handsome guy with sideburns and a rye, if somewhat resigned manner. He knew what he was doing though. He started cracking jokes with the kids right away.
我有种感觉，暗地里，不少妈妈自己也想试试。事实证明，我也没必要担心神奇罗伯特，那位魔术师。他是一个长着鬓角、举止冷峻但多少有些顺从的帅哥。不过他知道他在做什么。他立刻就开始跟孩子们讲笑话。
You must be Haley he said to one of the boys as he walked through the door. No, Peter said. I'm a boy and clapped his hands.
你一定是海莉，他走进门时对其中一个男孩说。不，彼得说。我是个男孩，并拍了拍手。
Hey, the magician said. No clapping. So all the kids clapped.
嘿，魔术师说。别拍手。所以所有的孩子都拍了手。
I said no clapping. By the time he started pulling eggs out of their noses, they were goners.
我说别拍手。等到他开始从他们的鼻子里变出鸡蛋时，他们就已经被俘虏了。
I chose that moment to run upstairs. I find I need a moment alone at regular intervals at these kiddie birthday bashes. Also at adult parties. In fact, I could use a moment alone right about now.
我选择那一刻跑上楼。我发现我需要在这些儿童生日派对上定期独处一会儿。在成人派对上也一样。事实上，我现在就需要独处一会儿。
But when I open the door to my bedroom, what do I find? Lying on my bed, surrounded by entire mountain ranges of miniature winter coats. Two of my adult guests holding hands. Their spouses were downstairs. I must say they played it cool.
但当我打开卧室门时，我发现了什么？躺在床上，被成堆的迷你冬装外套包围着。两位我的成年客人在牵手。他们的配偶在楼下。我不得不说他们表现得很冷静。
Headache, the woman said. Rubbing her temples. Not that I ask.
头痛，那女人说。揉着太阳穴。我没问。
Yeah, I said. These kids parties can be brutal. And I tell you, I left fast. I didn't want to ask. I certainly didn't want to now.
是啊，我说。这些儿童派对真是残忍。我告诉你，我溜得很快。我不想问。我当然也不想现在问。
And downstairs, the Amazing Robert was making cards disappear and reappear. But Trish, Katie's mom, she kept staring at the magician. I thought she disapproved of his tricks. But then she gave a little shriek. I know, she said. I knew I knew that magician. He has just come through a terrible divorce from a birthday clown. Which pretty much says it all, doesn't it?
楼下，神奇罗伯特正让牌消失又重现。但翠西，凯蒂的妈妈，她一直在盯着魔术师。我以为她不赞成他的戏法。但随后她发出一声小小的尖叫。我知道了，她说。我知道我认识那个魔术师。他刚刚经历了一场与生日小丑的可怕离婚。这几乎说明了一切，不是吗？
It's terrible getting older, the disappointments and the let-downs. But no child believes that. They want to get older. If you're seven, you can't wait to be nine. I mean, nine. That it's going to be the greatest. Because they think life just gets better and better and better the older you get. And we grown-ups, we know better. Or we think we do. Or at least we need to think we do. But I didn't have much time for such maudlin thought's. Frankly, convoluted ones. Because I knew sound was wafting in from the living room. A sound that is frankly, impossible to be maudlin about.
变老真是糟糕，那些失望和挫折。但没有孩子相信这一点。他们想变老。如果你七岁，你迫不及待想变九岁。我的意思是，九岁。那将会是最棒的。因为他们认为年纪越大，生活只会越来越好。而我们成年人，我们知道得更好。或者我们认为我们知道。或者至少我们需要认为我们知道。但我没时间做那种感伤的思考。坦率地说，是令人费解的思考。因为我知道客厅里飘来了声音。一个坦率地说，不可能让人感伤的声音。
[WHOOPEE CUSHION SOUNDS]
[放屁垫的声音]
They'd found the loot bags. Crass? Sure. Cheesy? Absolutely. Grown-up? Not at all. That's what I liked about it.
他们找到了礼品袋。粗俗？当然。俗气？绝对。成熟？一点也不。这就是我喜欢它的原因。
Ian Brown is the author of Man, Medium Rare and Freewheeling. And the host of a radio program called Talking Books on the CBC.
伊恩·布朗是《男人，半熟》和《自由奔放》的作者。也是加拿大广播公司名为《谈论书籍》的电台节目的主持人。
Coming up, more parental nudity. Very very, brief and very, very harmless parental nudity. Which is, frankly, the only way I can take it. I don't know about you. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，更多关于家长的裸露。非常非常简短且非常非常无害的家长裸露。这坦率地说，是我能接受的唯一方式。我不知道你们怎么样。那将在国际公共广播电台节目继续播出后的一分钟内发生。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we chose some theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show for father's day, stories about dads who have been removed from the pedestal of paternal grandeur. Dads who are entirely human scale. We have arrived at act three of our show.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天父亲节的节目，关于那些被从父亲庄严神坛上拉下来的父亲们的故事。完全是凡人比例的父亲们。我们已经进入节目的第三幕。
Act three, Legend of a Bankrobber's Son.
第三幕，银行劫匪之子的传奇。
Nick Flynn's father deserted the family not long after Nick was born. Nick did not know him at all. His father was a check forger and a bankrobber. And for a brief period in the '70s, served some time for it. Nick's mother, politically enough, worked for a bank. And at one point, after they split up, saw the dad on a wanted poster. She brought it home and showed his brother saying, that's your dad. Eventually, under rather odd circumstances, Nick and his father met, and started to get to know each other. Nick Flynn tells this story.
尼克·弗林的父亲在尼克出生后不久就抛弃了家庭。尼克根本不了解他。他父亲是个支票伪造者和银行劫匪。在70年代曾有短暂的一段时间因此入狱。尼克的母亲，从政治角度讲，在银行工作。有一次，在他们分居后，在通缉令上看到了他爸爸。她把它带回家展示给哥哥看，说，那是你们的爸爸。最终，在相当奇怪的情况下，尼克和他的父亲见了面，并开始了解对方。尼克·弗林讲述了这个故事。
At a certain point, I think I had already heard about my father being in prison and I knew that he was an alcoholic. I was probably 15 or so. I was actually drinking pretty heavily then also, and doing drugs. And my mother got concerned about it. I think she was afraid that I was just going to be like him. It was probably very difficult for her to have me in the house. She'd made a choice to leave a relationship like that and now here I was, sort of becoming that person.
在某个阶段，我想我已经听说我父亲在监狱里，而且我知道他是个酒鬼。我大概15岁左右。我当时也喝得很凶，还吸毒。我母亲对此很担心。我想她害怕我最终会变得像他一样。家里有我可能对她来说非常困难。她做出了离开那种关系的决定，而现在我却在这里，有点要变成那个人了。
I remember we were sitting in the living room of our house and she-- I'd probably come home one more night, like completely shattered. And I believe it was the next morning, like we woke up and she was just like, this isn't good. She sat me down and said, what did I plan to do with my life? At 15 I had no idea.
我记得我们当时坐在家里的客厅里，她——我可能又有一个晚上回家，像彻底崩溃了一样。我相信是第二天早上，我们醒来，她只是说，这不好。她让我坐下，问我打算用我的生活做什么？15岁时我毫无头绪。
We didn't have a lot of money growing up. My mother worked two or three jobs. And things were tight. I told her I planned to go into crime. It seemed like a reasonable thing to think of doing. That would be a way to get a lot of money fast. That was the career path I was considering.
我们成长过程中没多少钱。我母亲打两三份工。日子很紧。我告诉她我打算去犯罪。这听起来是个合理的想法。那样就能很快弄到很多钱。那是我当时考虑的职业道路。
But when I told her that she began to cry. I could see tears well up in her eyes. I tried to sort of back peddle and explain that I'd do sort of white collar victimless crime. And then she just left the room. She just walked out of the room.
但当我告诉她时，她开始哭泣。我可以看到泪水在她眼中涌出。我试图往回找补，解释说我会做那种白领的受害者犯罪。然后她就离开了房间。她就那样走出了房间。
Until I was 16, I think I'd seen him just two or three times. I actually remember looking for him. I remember thinking I would see him places because he had friends in Scituate, in my hometown. But by that point, my mother had a warrant on him for nonpayment of child support.
直到我16岁，我想我只见过他两三次。我其实记得自己曾找过他。我记得我以为能在某些地方见到他，因为他在我家乡西图阿特有朋友。但到那时，我母亲已经因为他拒绝支付抚养费而发出了逮捕令。
And then, when I was 16 was when my mother first showed me a letter that he sent. There's a lot of letters. I spent a couple weeks a couple of years ago going through all the letters he had sent me, pulling them together. The first letter that I have is from 1976. I just have written it's postmarked June 25. Signed dad. And he regrets for forgetting the date of my birthday. And then one of the lines in it is, "Tell me of yourself. I miss you both. And soon, very soon, I shall be known."
然后，当我16岁时，母亲第一次给我看了他寄来的一封信。有很多信。几年前我花了几周时间整理了他寄给我的所有信件。我有的第一封信来自1976年。我只写了邮戳是6月25日。签名是爸爸。他为忘了我生日日期表示遗憾。其中一行字是，“告诉我关于你的事。我非常想念你们俩。很快，非常快，我就会出名了。”
That "soon, very soon, I shall be known." One of the things about my father is that he identifies himself as a writer, as a poet. He has a sense of grandiosity about himself and what his achievements, his place in the world.
那个“很快，非常快，我就会出名了”。我父亲的特点之一是他认为自己是个作家，是个诗人。他对自己和他的成就，他在世界上的地位有一种宏大的自负感。
Often what he would do is he would take a letter from someone else and Xerox it, and then send it on to someone else. Like he has a correspondence with Ted Kennedy. He writes to him all the time. And being a senator, the senator, I think, just has someone who answers the letters for him. They'll often be that. Often he'll just sort of write something. Maybe a couple words and then there'd be maybe a Xeroxed letter from Ted Kennedy.
他经常会把别人的信复印，然后转发给别人。比如他和泰德·肯尼迪有通信往来。他总是写信给他。而身为参议员，我认为参议员只是有人代为回复这些信件。通常就会是那样。他往往只会写点东西。也许几个词，然后就会附上一封泰德·肯尼迪的复印信。
I have one here. I mean, I just got one. Actually, the most recent. I just got one a couple days ago. A letter from Ted Kennedy. The print is actually sort of falling apart because it's been Xeroxed so many times.
我这里有一封。我的意思是，我刚收到一封。其实是最新的。我几天前刚收到一封。泰德·肯尼迪的信。打印出来的文字因为被复印了太多次，已经有点模糊了。
"Dr Mr. Flynn, thank you for your recent correspondence advising me of your further views on critical issues facing us in Congress."
“弗林先生，感谢您最近的通信，告知我您对我们在国会面临的关键问题的进一步看法。”
It goes on, "Thank you again for writing."
接着是，“再次感谢您的来信。”
These are some lines from a letter that I received from my father in 1995.
这是我父亲在1995年寄给我的一封信中的几行字。
"We must have one love, one great love in our life. We are a nation of grunters. I fully intend to control Senator Kennedy's reelection. He shall win and I shall be named the head of the American Arts Council. It shall happen.
“我们一生中必须拥有一种爱，一种伟大的爱。我们是一个抱怨者的民族。我完全打算控制参议员肯尼迪的连任。他会赢，而我将被任命为美国艺术委员会主席。一定会实现。”
I do hope you both are well and earn some solid pursuits of solid goals in life."
“我希望你们俩都好，并追求人生中扎实的目标。”
And another letter from 1989.
还有一封1989年的信。
"I shall be able to do for American now what Mr. Solzhenitsyn has done for Russia. My works are waiting. It shall be soon.
“我现在能为美国做索尔仁尼琴为俄罗斯做过的事。我的作品在等待着。很快就会实现。”
And this is from 1987.
这是1987年的。
"Writers, especially poets are particularly prone to madness. Whether you like it or not, you are me. Eno the Beano tells me you are into drugs. If so, good luck."
“作家，尤其是诗人，特别容易疯狂。不管你喜不喜欢，你就是我。伊诺·比诺告诉我你在吸毒。如果是真的，祝你好运。”
By the early '80s, he had been-- I knew he was out of jail. I knew he was out of federal prison. And I knew he was driving a cab. I think a taxi in Boston. I knew something about him, but I hadn't seen him probably for 10, 12 years. And we finally did see each other. He got my phone number. And at some point, I believe it was in 1987, he called me up and said he was getting evicted from the rooming house he was in. He wanted me to come over and to-- he knew I had a pickup truck somehow and he wanted me to come over and to move all his stuff out of the house and out of his apartment.
到80年代初，他已经——我知道他出狱了。我知道他出了联邦监狱。我知道他在开出租车。我想是波士顿的一辆出租车。我对他了解一些，但我可能有10、12年没见他了。最后我们终于见了面。他弄到了我的电话号码。在某个时候，我相信是在1987年，他打电话给我，说他要被赶出他住的寄宿公寓了。他想让我过去，他不知怎么知道我有辆皮卡车，他想让我过去把他所有的东西从房子里、从他公寓里搬走。
This might have been the first time I ever talked to him. When I was a kid I don't think I talked to him. And then I'd gotten these letters from him, which I hadn't answered. He was pretty drunk when he called. He said that he was sitting behind his door with a shotgun waiting for the knob to turn. He wasn't going to let them take his stuff and he wasn't going to leave. That I should get over there.
这可能是我第一次和他说话。小时候我不认为我跟他说过话。然后我收到了他寄来的这些信，我没回信。他打电话时喝得烂醉。他说他正坐在门后拿着猎枪，等着门把手转动。他不打算让他们拿走他的东西，也不打算离开。我得赶过去。
So I actually brought a couple other friends, just for witnesses. And so we got over there. We got there and it was sort of an amazing scene. I knocked on his door and he said to come in. I went in and he was sitting in a tin tub naked in the middle of his room having a bath. And drinking vodka our of a silver challis. I'd never seen him before. Then he stood up naked in front of me covered with water. And it was shocking. It was a shocking scene.
所以我带了几个朋友去，只是作为证人。我们到了那里，那场面真是惊人。我敲了敲门，他让我进去。我走进去，他赤身裸体地坐在屋子中间的一个锡盆里洗澡。喝着银色圣餐杯里的伏特加。我以前从没见过他。然后他在我面前赤身裸体地站起来，身上沾满水。太令人震惊了。那是一个令人震惊的场面。
My friends and I stayed with him for maybe half an hour and I ended up giving him some money to put his stuff in storage. To hire a truck and to get a storage unit. I gave him a few hundred dollars. And then we left. And then he moved his stuff out.
我和朋友们陪了他大概半小时，我最后给了他一些钱用来存东西。雇了一辆车，租了一个储物单元。我给了他几百美元。然后我们离开了。后来他把东西搬走了。
And then the next time I saw him was maybe a couple months later. It was getting warmer. I remember it was sort of a warm day. Like maybe April or something. And I was riding my bike along the Charles River and he was sleeping on a bench on the Esplanade by the Charles River. I realized that at this point he was homeless.
下一次见到他大概是几个月后。天气变暖了。我记得那是个温暖的日子。就像四月什么的。我正沿着查尔斯河骑自行车，他在查尔斯河边的海滨长椅上睡觉。我意识到那时他无家可归了。
At that point, in 1987, I had been working with the homeless at a homeless shelter in Boston for three years. I'd been there for three years as a caseworker. I sort of had a sick feeling in my stomach that he would show up at the shelter where I worked. After seeing him on the bench, probably within a month he ended up at the shelter.
那时，在1987年，我已经在一个波士顿的无家可归者收容所为无家可归者工作了三年。我在那里做了三年个案工作者。我心里有种恶心的感觉，怕他会出现在我工作的收容所。在长椅上看到他后，大概一个月内，他果然到了收容所。
One day in the afternoon he walked into the shelter and he announced loudly to everyone that his son worked there and that he needed a bed. And demanded a bed. And then I came on for my shift later that day and the supervisor took me aside and told me what had happened. And asked me, he said that someone had come looking for a bed today that claimed to be my father. And I was shocked. It was a secret. I didn't want people to know this. I'd probably tell people that he'd been in prison. That he was a writer. That he was a failed writer. And all those things seemed actually sort of-- just seemed to add sort of a mystique. It's something you can just relate, like a good story.
有一天下午，他走进收容所，大声宣布他儿子在这里工作，他需要一张床。并要求给一张床。那天晚些时候我开始上班，主管把我叫到一边，告诉我发生了什么。并问我，他说今天有人来找床位，声称是我父亲。我惊呆了。这是个秘密。我不想让人们知道这个。我可能只会告诉人们他坐过牢。说他是个作家。是个失败的作家。所有这些事听起来其实还——只是一种神秘感。这就像是一个故事，你可以讲述一个好故事。
But then, when he becomes homeless, it goes up to another level. I felt riddled with shame that this man was my father. Which was confusing for me because I had worked with the homeless for three years and I had a lot of compassion for homeless people. But when it happened to someone in my family, to happen to my father, I felt utter shame that people would look at me and judge in a certain way. Whether that I was going to end up like him. That I was sort of crazy like him. Or why couldn't I help him? Why couldn't I do something? You know, I was his family. I lived in a place. Why didn't he live in my place?
但后来，当他变得无家可归，事情就到了另一个层面。这个男人是我父亲，我感到羞愧难当。这让我很困惑，因为我在无家可归者中工作了三年，我对无家可归者很有同情心。但当它发生在我的家人身上，发生在我的父亲身上时，我感到无比羞愧，人们会用那种方式看我、评判我。无论是认为我会变得和他一样。认为我像他一样疯狂。还是为什么我不能帮他？为什么我不能做点什么？你知道，我是他的家人。我有住的地方。为什么他不住在我这？
But then, I did not want him to be-- I had this sense that he had-- he hadn't really given me much in my life and now he was going to come and take away a job I had in some way. That he would come to my job and just sort of [BLEEP] that up. I wished he would go anywhere but where I worked.
但我不想让他——我有种感觉，他生命中没给我多少东西，现在他要来夺走我的工作。他会到我的工作地点，把那一切搞砸。我希望他去哪儿都行，除了我工作的地方。
He did all right for a while. He got a job. He was sort of a model homeless person. He had a day job at a labor pool. He would have a bad held for him by someone else. I didn't have a lot of interaction with him.
他好了一阵子。他找到了一份工作。他是个模范无家可归者。他在劳务中心有份日结工作。他会让人帮他占一张床。我和他没什么互动。
I remember him being in the lobby of the shelter and him coming in at night. I would have radar for when he came in. I would know when he was there. I would look over and see him go and get his bed ticket for the night. I probably wouldn't say anything to him. And then I would just sort of see him. And I'd judge whether he seemed drunk or not. Whether he seemed like it was just going to be a smooth transition from the day into the night. Or if it wasn't. Or if there was going to be a scene.
我记得他常在收容所大厅，晚上过来。他来时我会自动开启雷达。我会知道他在那儿。我会看过去，看他去拿夜里的床位卡。我可能什么都不会跟他说。然后我只是看着他。我会判断他看起来喝没喝醉。判断他看起来会不会是从白天到晚上顺利过渡。或者是不会。或者会不会闹事。
And there were a few times I remember meeting him actually, after work. At dawn when he was on his way to the labor pools to do work. And walking with him and talking. Actually, like outside the shelter. Like walking along and trying to figure out what was going on with him.
我有几次记得下班后碰到他。天亮时他正要去劳务中心干活。我陪他走路聊天。其实是在收容所外面。边走边试图弄清楚他身上发生了什么。
And I went back to the shelter recently this past winter for the first time. And talked to a lot of people who-- and asked them, what they were thinking of this. How we interacted. What I seemed like. What they thought. And most people said that they were just utterly confused. That they had no idea really what to-- how to treat me, how to treat him. And it seemed to them that I didn't want to talk about it. I wouldn't really give them a way into a conversation about this. I was just sort of maybe too freaked out and I didn't know what to say.
前段时间冬天我回到了收容所。和许多人谈了——问他们是怎么想的。我们是如何互动的。我看起来怎么样。他们怎么想。大多数人说他们彻底糊涂了。他们不知道该怎么办——该怎么对待我，怎么对待他。他们看起来好像我不想谈论这个。我真的没法和他们展开关于这个的谈话。我可能当时吓坏了，不知道该说什么。
I really don't know what I was feeling. I think I was feeling awful. I was feeling confused and it seemed like a nightmare to me, actually.
我真的不知道我当时在感觉什么。我觉得我感觉糟透了。我觉得很困惑，它对我来说简直是一场噩梦。
When my father showed up in 1987 in the shelter, I was actively drinking and using drugs. From what I remember, my drug increase probably-- my drug intake, I imagine, increased. I had totaled three vehicles. And all of them I had been drinking or doing drugs while I was driving.
1987年我父亲出现在收容所时，我正积极地酗酒和吸毒。据我记得，我的药物摄入量，我想，增加了。我撞坏了三辆车。而在所有的事故中，我开车时都喝了酒或吸了毒。
At one point, I had a motorcycle accident while I was drunk. It's not a good idea to ride a motorcycle when you're drunk. And ended up in the hospital, Lost my spleen.
有一次，我在喝醉时出了摩托车事故。醉酒骑摩托车不是个好主意。最后进了医院，切除了脾脏。
I would drink and smoke marijuana. You know, pretty much daily. I was sort of fitting a profile of someone who was on the way to some kind of ruin or something.
我会几乎每天喝酒和吸大麻。你知道，我基本符合一个正在走向毁灭的人的特征。
I looked at my father and he was 30 years older than me. He identified himself as a writer. I identified myself as a writer. He didn't take it seriously. He didn't take his situation seriously. And maybe I didn't either at that point. Somehow I was able to gain perspective by looking at him. And I'm not sure why I couldn't gain perspective by looking at all the other homeless guys that were there, and drinking and nose diving. But somehow looking at him and feeling like, OK, even though I don't know him as a father, there's some connection between us. And if I keep going like I'm going, I'm going to end up like him. It terrified me.
我看着我父亲，他比我大30岁。他自认为是作家。我也自认为是作家。他不当回事。他没把他的处境当回事。也许那时我也不当回事。不知何故，我通过看着他能够获得视角。我不确定为什么我看收容所里其他那些也在喝得烂醉坠落的无家可归者时无法获得这种视角。但不知何故，看着他，觉得，好吧，即使我不把他当作父亲，我们之间也有某种联系。如果我继续这样下去，我会变得像他一样。这让我很恐惧。
And after he'd been there for two years, I ended up getting into therapy and getting sober. And I think it actually has a lot to do with that, with seeing my father and seeing what could happen to someone's life. I sort of had to see something that extreme I think to realize what a potential fate that I could end up in.
在他待了两年后，我最终开始接受治疗并戒酒戒毒了。我想这确实和那有很大关系，看到我父亲，看到一个人可能发生什么。我想我必须看到那种极端的事，才能意识到我最终可能会面临什么样的命运。
He had it together enough to realize that when he turned 60 he was eligible for senior housing. And when he turned 60, he actually got an apartment in subsidized housing, section 8 housing.
他过得还算不错，能够意识到当他60岁时，他有资格住老年公寓。当他60岁时，他确实在补贴性住房，第8节住房里分到了一套公寓。
I began filming him probably five years after that, like in middle of the '90s.
我大概在五年前开始拍摄他，在90年代中期。
As I had learned in the 90 days I had been there what would happen. I would have looked like Toulouse Lautrec. They'd have shot the balls off at the knees. Not even higher.
就像我在那里待的90天里学到的一样。我会长得像图卢兹-劳特雷克。他们会把蛋蛋射到膝盖上。甚至还不用太高。
My proposal was that I was going to seek out and interview the men that had known my mother. The men that had been in my mother's life, for a year, or for five years, or for however long.
我的提议是我要寻找并采访认识我母亲的男人。那些出现在我母亲生命里的男人，不管是待了一年，五年，还是多久。
And so the first time I really went to look for my father was with a video camera and I interviewed him. Every time I'd go to him for the next three or four years, I'd bring a camera with me. And just his story sort of kept coming.
所以我第一次去找我父亲是带着摄像机，我采访了他。在接下来的三四年里，我每次去找他都会带上摄像机。他的故事就那样源源不断地涌现。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], Lewisberg, Atlanta, Marion, Illinois, which was built to replace Alcatraz. I was there. And I had the pleasure. I mean, the pleasure speaking as Solzhenitsyn. I mean, I want to know what the [BLEEP] I was writing about. I was thinking, Jesus, Solzhenitsyn is going to jump with envy when he sees this [BLEEP] story. He and Dostoyevsky both wrote about their adventures in Russian prisons heavily.
[听不清]，刘易斯堡，亚特兰大，马里昂，伊利诺伊州，那是为了取代恶魔岛而建的。我就在那里。而且我很荣幸。我的意思是，作为索尔仁尼琴发言很荣幸。我的意思是，我想知道我到底在写什么[哔]。我当时想，天哪，索尔仁尼琴看到这个[哔]故事一定会嫉妒地跳起来。他和陀思妥耶夫斯基都写了很多他们在俄罗斯监狱里的冒险经历。
All he wanted to do was to give me his three step plan for how to rob a bank. Which seemed to be his version of fatherly advice. We had never spoken before and this was the first real conversation we had. Was he laid out his method of robbing banks to me.
他想做的就是告诉我他那套如何抢劫银行的三步计划。这似乎成了他版本的“父亲的忠告”。我们以前从没谈过话，这是我们第一次真正的谈话。他向我展示了他的抢银行方法。
Three steps in the whole program. Step one, open an account. Open an account.
整个计划就三步。第一步，开个账户。开个账户。
He sort of kept forgetting the steps also. It involved getting someone to steal some checks from an insurance company and then to forge those checks. Make a whole series of forged checks. And then to open dummy bank accounts around the country. It was sort of elaborate. Elaborate and convoluted. And ultimately, a failed enterprise.
他也总是忘记这些步骤。这涉及让人从一家保险公司偷些支票，然后伪造那些支票。制作一系列伪造支票。然后全国各地开设虚拟银行账户。这有点复杂。复杂而绕口。最终，是一个失败的尝试。
Step one, I was given like a hundred $100 bills. Well, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Driven to the bank by [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Go in with my story. Always a female teller. Always go to a young female teller. A guy is no good. They're generally homosexuals.
第一步，我得到了像一百张100美元的钞票。好吧，[听不清]。被[听不清]开车送到银行。带着我的故事走进去。总是找女柜员。总是去找年轻的女柜员。男人没用。他们通常是同性恋。
When I first met up with him, we went to a soup kitchen where he ate. I did a tape in there and he introduced me to other people he ate with, the other people in the soup kitchen, who had known him for years since he goes to the soup kitchen several times a week.
我第一次见他时，我们去了他吃饭的救济站。我在那录了音，他把我介绍给一起吃饭的其他人，那些认识他多年的人，因为他一周去好几次救济站。
This is your son?
这是你儿子？
This is my son, Nicholas.
这是我儿子，尼古拉斯。
How do you do?
你好吗？
Hello.
你好。
This is a good friend of mine. I'm not kidding you.
这是我的一位好朋友。我没骗你。
I thought you were just somebody he picked up on the way making a documentary.
我以为你只是他做纪录片时路上随便捡的一个人。
I can't believe a handsome kid like you belongs to him.
我不敢相信像你这么帅的孩子居然是他生的。
It was the mother. The mother was beautiful. I was lucky.
那是母亲的功劳。母亲很漂亮。我很幸运。
He was very proud that this is my son. And no one really believed that he had a son. I said, yeah, I was his son. And he bragged to people that I was working at Columbia University.
他非常自豪，这是我儿子。真的没人相信他有儿子。我说，是啊，我是他儿子。他向别人吹嘘我在哥伦比亚大学工作。
What's your name?
你叫什么名字？
Walter.
沃尔特。
Walter. Nice to meet you, Walter.
沃尔特。很高兴见到你，沃尔特。
He teaches at Columbia University. My kid. Imagine that. For writing.
他在哥伦比亚大学教书。我的孩子。想象一下。教写作。
That's a miracle.
那真是个奇迹。
Well again, his mother had brains. I got to get another coffee. How old are you anyway?
好吧，还是那句话，他母亲有脑子。我得再去弄杯咖啡。你到底多大了？
I'm 35.
我35岁。
Are you that old?
你老了吗？
Yeah, 35.
是啊，35岁。
When's the last time I saw you?
我上次见你是什么时候？
Four years ago.
四年前。
How the hell you'd go to the NYU [UNINTELLIGIBLE] school? I don't know what promoted you. How'd you go there? You majored in writing?
你怎么进纽约大学[听不清]学校的？我不知道是什么提拔了你。你怎么去那里的？你是主修写作的？
Yeah.
是的。
Struggling fully. He knows how successful his father is as a writer.
他完全是个挣扎者。他知道他的父亲作为一名作家有多成功。
A lot of times I'm very frustrated when I go and meet with him because it seems like he tells the same stories over and over again. They seem very disconnected to reality. But those few times where I have felt some connection, it does seem that he's just let his guard down a little bit and let me glimpse at his struggle in some way. You know, what connects us. He actually wrote me a letter right after-- he sent me a couple letters after my book of poems came out.
很多时候我去找他见面都会感到非常沮丧，因为他似乎总是重复说同样的故事。他们似乎与现实完全脱节。但有几次我觉得有一些联系，似乎他确实放下了防备，让我瞥见了他的挣扎。你知道，是什么联系着我们。其实他确实给我写了一封信——我的诗集出来后他寄了两封信给我。
In the first one it just says, "Dear Nick, your book is a classic. Love, your father." That's a unique letter. Because the classic has only been a word that he's ever reserved for his own work. And so for him to apply that to my is just sort of him turning, even if just for a second and sort of looking at me and saying something about what I've done.
第一封信上写着，“亲爱的尼克，你的书是一部经典。爱你的，父亲。”那是一封独特的信。因为“经典”这个词是他一直只保留给自己作品的词。所以他把它用在我的书上，只是他的一种转变，即使只是一瞬间，他转过身看着我说了一些关于我做的事情的话。
There has to be a reason that I've held onto his letters for all these years. There has to be some sort of reason, something I've been waiting for, or looking for, or hoping for. And yes, something like this is sort of maybe as close as I'll get to it.
我这么多年来一直留着他的信肯定是有原因的。一定有某种理由，我在等待、寻找或希望得到什么。是的，像这样的一点点，也许就是我能得到的接近了。
I would like to have sort of one of those deep, connecting moments with him. But I'm not really sure if I've achieved that yet. Again, I'm actually not even sure if at this point, I would hope for or-- sure. Maybe you always hope for it, you just sort of deny that hope or something. I don't know if I even hope for it at this point. It's almost enough just to sit in front of him. To go to his room and sit with him for an hour. And just see where he is. And tell him, whatever. I'll tell him one thing about myself. If he hears it, that's great. If he doesn't hear it, that's fine.
我希望能和他有那种深刻的联系时刻。但我真的不确定我是否已经达到了。再说一次，我甚至不确定在这一点上，我是会希望还是——确定。也许你总是希望得到它，你只是否认那种希望什么的。我不知道我在这点上是否还抱有希望。光是坐在他面前就足够了。去他的房间坐一个小时。看看他在哪。告诉他，随便什么。告诉他一件关于我自己的事。如果他听进去了，那太好了。如果他没听见，也没关系。
I don't expect him to give me anything at this point. It's almost enough just to go and see him. It somehow calms me enough or settles my soul enough just to go and have some relationship at all with him. I'm sort of down to the real basic, like really stripped down to the most basic father there can be. He just is my father and there's nothing I can do about that. There's nothing he can do about that. I go and I sit and I have a relationship with this person who is my father.
我没指望他现在能给我什么。光是去看他就够了。光是建立哪怕一点点关系，在某种程度上就足够让我平静或安抚我的灵魂。我基本已经降到了最基本的程度，真的很剥离到了父亲最基本的状态。他就是我父亲，对此我无能为力。他也无能为力。我去坐着，和他这个是我父亲的人保持着一种关系。
Nick Flynn's book of poems is called Some Ether . He's working on a book in which his dad figures prominently.
尼克·弗林的诗集名为《某种醚》。他正在写一本书，他父亲在其中占有重要地位。
Well, our program was produced by Wendy Dorr and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jonathan Goldstein, and Starlee Kine. Senior producer Julie Snyder. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, [UNINTELLIGIBLE], Rebecca Carroll, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Paul McCarthy. Musical help from Mr. John Connors.
我们的节目由温迪·多尔和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、乔纳森·戈德斯坦和斯塔莉·凯恩。高级制片人朱莉·斯奈德。特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、[听不清]、丽贝卡·卡罗尔、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克和法律顾问萨拉·沃威尔。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼和保罗·麦卡锡提供制作帮助。约翰·康纳斯先生提供音乐协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
If you'd like to buy a cassette copy of this program, a little late for Father's Day, but still, you can own it. Call us here at WBEZ in Chicago 312-832-3380. Or visit our website where you can also listen to our programs for free, absolutely free at www.thisamericanlife.org.
如果您想购买本节目的卡带副本，虽然离父亲节有点晚了，但没关系，您可以拥有它。请致电芝加哥WBEZ电台312-832-3380。或者访问我们的网站，您也可以在那里免费、绝对免费地收听我们的节目，网址是www.thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助信息]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I tell you, the staff of the show just keeps complaining about Torey lately. They run into him in the restroom and I don't get what is going on with him these days.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。我告诉你，节目的工作人员最近一直抱怨托里。他们在洗手间遇到他，我搞不懂这些天他到底怎么了。
Be naked, flexing like this divorcee, pumping iron Arnold Schwarzenegger.
赤身裸体，像那个离婚后疯狂练铁的阿诺德·施瓦辛格一样摆姿势。
I'm IRA Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多美国生活的故事回来。
He'd want me to grab his biceps to see how they were growing. It was just absolutely horrible.
他想让我抓他的二头肌看看它们长得怎么样了。这简直太可怕了。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。